well unless you have completely checked
out over the last three days as I did
you certainly have heard by now that
Donald Trump claims he will be arrested
tomorrow there has never been an arrest
or indictment of a sitting or former
president in the United States if Trump
is right if he's telling the truth slash
correctly informed which is still a
question mark this will be one of the
biggest news stories in decades in the
United States and the world quite
frankly as the globe waits to see Will
trump be even potentially held
accountable for any of the Myriad things
that he did while he was president and
in the lead-up during the 2016 campaign
where do we even start well let's start
with how this all started with Donald
Trump's outrageous all caps posts
riddled with grammatical and spelling
errors to his social media platform
truth social
call it whatever the hell you want look
at the news and and it is news quite
frankly that Donald Trump predicted his
arrest on that platform let's go right
into it and again if you're not if
you're listening
these are these messages are in all
capital letters which I think is just
another one of these little details
let's get right into it quote our nation
is now third world and dying the
American dream is dead the radical left
anarchists have stolen our presidential
election and with it the heart of our
our country I'm reading it as written
Trump writing Stalin of course a famous
German Christmas bread riddled with nuts
spices as well as candied or dried fruit
the anarchists have Stalin our
presidential election and with it the
heart of our our country American
Patriots are being arrested and held in
captivity like animals while criminals
and leftist thugs are allowed to roam
the streets that's not true
killing and burning with no retribution
that's a lie millions are flooding
through our open borders and the wrong
borders spelling borders like if you
were a border at a boarding house many
from prisons and mental institutions
that is also a lie the crime and
inflation are destroying our very way of
life now illegal leaks from a corrupt
and highly political Manhattan District
Attorney's office which has allowed new
records to be set in violent crime well
the violent crime rate is higher in
Oklahoma City
than it is in New York City but why let
the facts get in the way of a good all
caps rant Trump continuing and whose
leader is funded by George Soros
indicate that with no crime being able
to be proven and based on an old and
fully debunked by numerous other
prosecutors fairy tale the Far and Away
leading Republican candidate and former
president of the United States of
America will be arrested on Tuesday of
next week I know that that's an
incoherent word salad but Trump is
saying they're going to arrest him
tomorrow
protests take our nation back Trump
demands and then continuing the calls
for protest and what is increasingly
concerningly going to be a violent
protest which we know Trump supporters
are capable of remember January 6th
Trump posting more quote it's time we
are a nation in steep decline being led
into World War III by a crooked
politician who doesn't even know he's
alive but who is surrounded by evil and
Sinister people who based on their
actions on defunding the police there
has been no defunding destroying our
military the military is fine open
borders the borders are not open and no
voter ID well voter ID depends on each
state inflation which is down raising
taxes Biden hasn't done that and much
more can only hate our now failing USA
we just can't allow this anymore they're
killing our nation as we sit back and
watch we must save America
protest protest protest and then finally
continuing this morning with these all
caps tirades quote the lead prosecutor
for the corrupt Manhattan DA's office
worked as a lawyer for crooked Hillary
Clinton and her Law Firm left this
Democrat firm with others to volunteer
to quote get Donald Trump at the DA's
office for free
he quit in a huff when D.A Bragg said
there was no case here he then
unethically and illegally wrote and
published a book about the case while it
was going on this is unheard of stuff
the case is now completely compromised
and reports are that Mark pomerance is
in trouble this is all wild stuff so let
me break it down for you in in with
clear terms
no president has ever been arrested nor
indicted Trump claims he will become the
first tomorrow there have been two
American Presidents subjected to
criminal investigations those were
Richard Nixon and yes Donald Trump Nixon
of course resigned from the presidency
before he could be impeached over the
Watergate scandal and that involved the
break-in at the Democratic National
Committee headquarters and the attempts
of course to cover it up Nixon was never
indicted
and uh Trump may be indicted Trump could
also be wrong and Trump could also be
lying I believe that this if it happens
politically will make Trump stronger
except if there are more indictments I
don't believe this case which is about
Stormy Daniels is the strongest case
against Trump however it's possible as
we've said before that prosecutors are
saying to themselves I have a case
I have a case against Trump but I don't
want to be the first to indict not the
first to indict Trump the first to
indict any former president so we may
have at the federal level we may have in
Georgia we may have the Tish James uh
investigation remember this is another
investigation they may be waiting for
another indictment first to then say now
I'm ready
I didn't have the testicular fortitude
ovarian fortitude whatever term you want
to use to be the first to indict Trump
but I am certainly willing to be second
or third and this may be
When the Levy Breaks for our Led
Zeppelin fans
um and in that case I think it will
weaken Trump if it just overwhelms him
with criminal cases however
I think if this is the only indictment
it will Galvanize Trump's supporters
and help him in his Republican primary
we will get to that later let's next
talk about how will Maga react if Donald
Trump is arrested Donald Trump claims he
will be arrested tomorrow will he I
don't know is Trump lying maybe is Trump
confused possibly often is the case but
if Trump is indicted if Trump is
arrested what will be the reaction from
magas well here are the five reactions I
expect number one we've already seen
this one
investigators already resigned because
there was no case so you know that this
case is bogus wrong
didn't happen we covered this at the
time
the truth is that investigators resigned
because they came to believe even though
we are finding evidence against Trump we
don't believe there's any real
willingness to indict him so we're
wasting our time the right Wingers are
defending Trump by saying investigators
resigned because there was no evidence
the truth is investigators resigned
because there was evidence but they
thought it was all for nothing because
nobody would actually indict Trump
if Trump is indicted they will have been
wrong but it is a lie that is being told
that's reaction number one the
investigators already decided there was
no case no they did not number two and
they're already saying this the focus
really should be on Hunter Biden and
there's a few different versions of this
defense and one is they are arresting
Trump
to distract from Hunter Biden makes no
sense whatsoever
the the legal the the bodies that are
investigating Hunter Biden uh are not
are are not necessarily the ones that
would be indicting Trump or arresting
Trump complete fabrication no evidence
whatsoever response number three from
the magas Democrats are doing this
because Trump is surging against Biden
in the 2024 polls ER wrong we actually
need only look at the polling to figure
this out and consistently Ron DeSantis
is stronger against Biden than is Trump
so the facts conflict we have a new uh
Emerson College poll highly rated
pollster which says Biden is losing to
DeSantis but leading Trump well that
doesn't really go with what Trump is
claiming we have a um we have a
Quinnipiac University poll which finds
that Biden leads DeSantis by only one
but leads Trump by four
so this is another claim that they are
making Democrats are doing this because
Trump is getting so strong in the
polling they need to do something to
hurt him no in fact it is DeSantis who
is stronger in the polling number four
they will say and they already did this
over the weekend on Newsmax and
elsewhere this is evidence of the
two-tier justice system one system of
justice for republicans and one system
of justice for Democrats ER wrong there
is a two-tier justice system but it is
that for the rich who can negotiate
their surrenders without having to be
handcuffed and all these things and then
everybody else we have a two-tier
justice system but it is not Republicans
and Democrats and then lastly number
five defense is these charges related to
the Stormy Daniels hush money are very
very weak I actually agree with that
defense My Hope Is as I said in the last
segment that this is just the beginning
and that the levy will break with these
charges if indeed they are coming we
don't know that for sure
and that then other prosecutors
federally maybe in Georgia which I
believe is actually the strongest case
in Georgia other charges will come
forward and that this will only be the
beginning but I agree actually with the
magas the Stormy Daniels situation is
not the strongest set of facts
for an arrest and indictment against
Donald Trump so those are the five
defenses that I expect many of which
inversions we are already seeing let's
take a quick break and after the break
we will talk about some of the other
aspects of this they're talking about
George Soros or I should say George
shorosh as they often I don't know why
the the people who really don't like
George Soros seem unable to say his last
name correctly and so many other things
stay with us on what could be the eve of
an historic day of a historic day of
both potentially on the David Pacman
show youtube.com slash the David Pacman
show make sure you're subscribed folks
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
the David pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program I implore you
to support the work that we do if you
find it worthwhile otherwise don't worry
about it if you hate this by no means
should you support it but if you do find
this worthwhile sign up at
joinpakman.com very quick very easy
cheap and comes with great benefits
strong perks which you can read about at
joinpakman.com let's take a brief break
from the potentially uh impending arrest
of failed former president Donald Trump
to talk about why the modern American
right wing loves authoritarianism and
authoritarian leaders you know it's
important to contextualize phenomena
that we observe in the modern world one
such phenomena is indeed one such
phenomenon is that modern Republicans
and right-wingers and mega trumpists and
and so on just seem to have a real soft
spot for increasingly authoritarian
policy fees and declarations why is this
and how did this come to be first and
foremost when we talk about
authoritarianism at its core what we're
talking about is a political system in
which the government has massive amounts
of power and authority over its citizens
it's a system that values control over
freedom and it relies on obedience and
compliance from the population
why does that sound weird when we think
about Republicans well it sounds weird
because it's the opposite of what they
claim Republicans have claimed for a
long time and still do
that they're about freedom and liberty
and not regulating people and not
regulating corporations and yet they
abandon those principles immediately
when the outcomes would conflict with
their worldview and they also seem to
glamorize the authoritarian leaders of
other countries and this includes under
Mega trumpism everybody from Putin and
duterte to bolsonaro and Orban and so
many others erdogan and many others that
we've talked about so why is it that so
many modern right-wingers are attracted
to this type of system there are a few
reasons and it's a combination of
fear-based motivation ignorance now some
of you might just say dumb Schmucks okay
I'm being a little more respectful and
I'm saying ignorance of facts and a
desperate desire for power those are the
three aspects that I would point to and
we can talk about each of these let's
first talk about fear
fear-based politics works much better
with Republicans as your targets and
when I say Target let's be honest
Republican voters are the targets of
Republican elected officials Republican
elected officials have accurately
assessed that in part because of what
have been quite frankly called brain
differences in right Wingers as well as
uh sort of value systems
right Wingers are very afraid of change
they're very afraid of others they're
afraid of difference and so it's really
effective to use authoritarianism as a
way to maintain control even if they
want freedom and liberty because you
tell them as a right winger as a
right-wing elected official folks all
these things you're afraid of
Twitter censoring conservatives and
brown people storming the border and uh
what does Trump call them insane asylums
emptying out into the United States and
immigrants taking your jobs and China
taking your stuff and whatever
in order to get them to agree to the
authoritarianism
you say I will use the authoritarianism
to uh help protect you from all these
things I have made you afraid of so fear
gets them to go with the
authoritarianism even when they say I
like freedom I like Liberty secondly
there's ignorance okay
I know people are going to find this
offensive to some degree the magas will
find this offensive there are a lot of
these folks particularly Trump's
followers that don't know what is
happening and so when they are told hey
you know what I can fix this thing I've
made you afraid of if you just give me
the power to do why I'll protect you
from X if you give me the power to do
why
they don't understand that it's just not
going to happen it's just not gonna I
will protect you from China by passing
tariffs
well but the tariffs are paid by
American come they don't know so they go
yes protect us from China by passing the
tariffs or I will protect you from brown
people raping women and children and
taking your jobs with a wall sure that
yeah sounds like that'll work I will
support you because of that and so
ignorance allows the authoritarianism to
grow and grow and grow
and then thirdly and I think sort of uh
uh you know finally here is the desire
for power the right sees many of these
authoritarian leaders and ideas as a way
to gain and maintain power over others a
power which they feel justified in
wanting because they believe that they
are morally correct and correct on
policy and whatever the case may be they
believe we would be the ones in charge
under such a system we would rather
freedom and liberty we would but
everything other than what we believe in
is really dangerous and we're scared of
it and it's whatever and so since we
would be the ones in power then it's
okay to impose this authoritarianism and
uh that that is the way that it would
ultimately stay now these are
generalizations not all right-wingers
are attracted to authoritarianism the
ones that are might only be motivated by
fear and their ignorance rather than
desire for power
or maybe it's desire for power and fear
and they're not really ignorant but
they've just miscalculated in some way
this is why the American right wing
overall on average is attracted to
authoritarianism and then you have two
more elements to this yes there's the
double standard okay they claim to be
about small government except when they
say oh no no the government needs to
tell Twitter exactly what to do wait I
thought you were against regulation yeah
but except when they're censoring
conservatives on Twitter but are they no
but that doesn't matter they've already
bought into that so there's the double
standard and then secondly I think in
this kind of addendum it's also
important to understand the connection
between right-wingers supporting
authoritarianism and populist rhetoric
and I've spoken before
about how populism is not a set of
policies it is a rhetoric and it's a way
of talking to people there is left-wing
populism and right-wing populism and
again some people go no there isn't
David
there is populist rhetoric from the
right and left
the populist rhetoric from the right is
often used to justify horrible things
right Bernie and Tucker Carlson will
both say the middle class has been
screwed and passed over and not helped
the way it should have been in this
country for a long time great a lot of
people will agree with that Tucker will
say and so to protect you from that we
have to keep the dirty poor immigrants
out and prevent antifa from taking your
house or whatever the case may be that's
important not to ignore
which is that much of the support for
its authoritarianism from the right has
come on the heels of populist rhetoric
from right wing Heroes Heroes to them
like Tucker and Trump and others that's
my sense of the love affair with
authoritarianism in the modern American
right wing I welcome your comments uh to
go beyond that let me know in an email
let me know in a comment we'll do a
follow-up soon
the number one
puppet master and this is really their
word not mine that is now being blamed
not only for orchestrating Trump's
possible arrest happening Tuesday but
also Ron desantis's campaign is
this might not come as a surprise the
nearly 100 year old Jewish man George
Soros I know how could he be controlling
everything how could it be so effective
it doesn't make any sense well this is
where they're going we already have
multiple clips from the past few days
where on Fox News and elsewhere
the right is already starting to say
Soros is involved in what may be the
arrest of trump here's one clip from I
believe this is the weekend Fox and
Friends uh March 19th yeah I believe
this is the weekend Fox and Friends
talking about how Soros and globalists
must be to blame here so let me ask you
the question how many black lives have
you sacrificed under a higher crime city
with increased murder rates to devote a
limited number of resources to the
priority of pursuing a weak case against
Donald Trump how many black lives was
this political stunt worth what you
learn from the left is that they don't
really care about black lives or the
working class or the poor you know this
is a George Soros funded D.A and he has
to pay his master back and this is
exactly his master folks this is
oh my goodness oh just overtly copying
the anti-semitic rhetoric of the it's
the Jewish master who must be paid he
wants money that money grubbing
90-something year old
multi-billionaire George Soros wait that
does that make doesn't matter this is
the story George Soros and so many of
those uh
happened to Donald Trump they want to
put an end to him
um you know at George Soros a globalist
no question that Donald Trump and his
ideas which are now being yeah
globalished internationalist Trotsky
socialist unlike Obama trudeoma Crown
there it is and by the way we'll get to
what Alex Jones thinks about all this a
little bit later Marjorie Taylor green
also invoking George Soros they're all
on message you've got to hand it to them
it is a war it's a political war
um and that is what they've waged
against President Trump his
administration his staff his supporters
and anyone that aligns themselves with
Maga and what this D.A this Manhattan
D.A is talking about doing he is serving
his master who is George Soros there it
is I mean folks it's quite literally the
same language this is Marjorie Taylor
green on pillow TV earlier it was you
know the weekend's second stringers on
Fox and Friends they are on message that
is for damn sure and the Democrat Party
in the globe herbalist Elites that do
not care about America they don't care
about Americans anymore they see Trump
as their number one enemy and Maga is
the force that they have to take out and
that is why this D.A is considering
indicting president Trump all right so
Soros and the globalist
are the ones responsible but it's not
just for Trump's arrest they are also
claiming that Soros is responsible for
Ron desantis's potential candidacy which
hasn't even started yet there's a
handful of these I could play but I will
only play one this is just a random
person waiting in line at Trump's recent
event in Iowa bringing up oh no no Soros
is behind DeSantis is anybody talking
about any other person for president
other than Donald J Trump any other name
yeah there you go Soros money is behind
DeSantis as well so this is there's a
lot of scholarship about this and just
to be like completely accurate let me
just say 92 years old okay so he's not
quite yet approaching a hundred but he's
in his 90s the idea behind the Soros
conspiracy theories the person doing it
isn't necessarily intending to promote
anti-Semitism they may not even really
understand the whole back story but we
have to be realistic and George soros's
Jewish identity is widely known and the
origins of many of these conspiracies
are linked to those who understand and
are aware now I know some of you will
say well some of these people don't
necessarily know that Soros is Jewish I
grant you that but it's still important
to understand that the Soros conspiracy
theories are in extra linked in
um to very well-known anti-semitic
tropes like for example
Soros Rich Jewish guy controlling
banking or controlling Media or working
to destabilize a country or working to
infiltrate modern society with Marxism
or whatever the case may be and it all
goes back to those anti-semitic tropes
that many of us know all too well and
it's important to understand sort of
like the Genesis of that so Soros really
a busy guy now at 92
involved in the santis campaign and
Trump's arrest and all of it the
question next becomes whatever it is
that these right-wingers believe about
the possible arrest of Donald Trump are
they going to Riot we know
that Trump supporters are willing to
commit great acts of heinous violence in
the name of trump how do we know that
because they did it on January 6 2021.
and hundreds of their cases are still
being adjudicated and sentences are
being handed out so immediately the
concern has been
are they going to Riot tomorrow if Trump
is arrested are they going to Riot are
they going to protest Trump calling for
them to protest protest protest Trump's
saying it is time it is time to quote
take our nation back when his followers
try to take things it often gets very
very ugly Business Insider reporting
Trump issued a siren Call for his
supporters to protest and take our
nation back he made the call after
claiming without evidence that he will
be arrested Tuesday his lawyers said
they have no knowledge of the impending
arrest and increasingly there is this
question as to whether they will become
violent will they become violent the
Manhattan district attorney says and
this is weirdly cut off and I apologize
that attempts to intimidate his office
will not be tolerated after Donald Trump
calls for protest Alvin Bragg sought to
reassure staffers that they will indeed
be safe
here is my thought on this I am
maintaining cautious optimism that
Trump's followers won't Riot if he's
arrested
at least not in New York City they may
ride somewhere but but at least not in
New York City and here's a couple
different logistical things
New York City is not a hotbed for Trump
support
ularly not Manhattan where presumably
this arrest and indictment will will
take place
um
many of these folks would have to go to
Manhattan in order to Riot in Manhattan
the site of Trump's arrest if it happens
there and quite frankly it's kind of
expensive to get over those bridges and
next thing you know they'll be paying
what 15 bucks to come into the City and
then 70 bucks to park during the day and
I I'm hoping quite frankly this may be
naive but I'm hoping that the financial
element of this will be a deterrent for
them to come and actually protest and
become violent in Manhattan so first of
all hopefully that doesn't happen and
hopefully it doesn't happen at all now
that being said it is possible that they
will do something they may go to
Mar-A-Lago as a sign of support and so
hopefully like that wouldn't get violent
but of course going to Mar-A-Lago when
Trump's in New York for the arrest I
don't know is that maybe it's hard to
know what will sort of pacify these
folks maybe they will go to Washington
DC
not completely clear to me but I think
at this point
I don't have too much to say other than
I hope and am cautiously optimistic that
there will not be another horrifying
anti-American anti-democratic anti-law
and Order day of rioting like there was
on January 6 2021 let me know in the
comments on Instagram on YouTube send an
email info davidpackman.com do you
expect rioting if Trump is arrested and
if it happens will Maga just say it
wasn't them it was BLM or some other
Trope that they'll pull out the way they
did on January 6. let me know what you
think
don't forget that the best way to
support the David packman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
I want to look at a few clips from an
event that took place in South Carolina
over the weekend the event is called
Vision 24 the national conservative
Forum a couple of interesting speakers
there we will get to Nikki Haley who
spoke there but I want to start with
Tulsi gabber now Tulsi gabbard is
someone who started as a democratic
congresswoman who ran for president back
in 2020
extraordinarily transparent grifter
which unfortunately summoned my audience
and in concert in left-wing media fell
for Hook Line and Sinker but she is no
longer a Democrat and she now promotes
anti-vaxx and she promotes all sorts of
crazy stuff the grift is up except it
kind of has only just started because
everything Tulsi is doing is her most
direct path to making money and I'll
explain that in a moment but Tulsi
gabbard spoke at this conservative forum
and I have to tell you she is truly a
sick person in this first clip Tulsi
revives the completely debunked notion
of Democrats supporting abortion after
birth or as you and I might call it the
killing of children this is of course
not true it's been widely debunked let's
look at what tools see now has the
audacity to say remember this was the
last real liberal according to someone
on the left
you celebrate
I couldn't believe it when I saw it in
this last state of the union speech how
many members of Congress are walking
around with a big abortion pin on their
suit jacket right incredible that they
feel a need to support that to show that
they support
women's rights to make medical decisions
in the context of a supreme court and a
Republican party that is hell-bent on
attacking that right a shocking that
Democrats would show that hey we support
women's rights
not just advocating for but celebrating
abortion on depend on demand without
exception
all the way up until birth or even after
birth normalizing and fantasy we've seen
this in places like New York and in
other states what so this this is
straight up untrue so let's break it
down into two parts until birth and then
after birth
even until birth is very deceptive and
I'll explain to you why
so-called late-term abortions right the
kind that would need to be approved
under special circumstances in many
state laws are extraordinarily rare
Republicans continue doing this thing
where they love to pretend you can be
you know 37 and a half weeks pregnant
and show up and say you know what I'd
like to end the pregnancy OB gyns have
extensively testified under oath that it
doesn't happen and that if it did it
wouldn't be something that 99.9 of OB
gyns would even do these are extremely
rare situations that in almost every
case relate to extreme circumstances
things that are discovered about the
health of the fetus or the or the health
of the mother it is insanely rare under
one percent of abortions are performed
after 21 weeks never mind 32 weeks 34
weeks the way these people want to talk
about insanely rare and the idea of ah
you know what my due dates next week I
think I want an abortion
almost imaginary beyond that this entire
after birth abortion I mean just it's
it's completely flat fabricated and
Tulsi of all people is now going with it
just disgusting person truly disgusting
person that she has debased herself in
this way then she does the elitist cabal
stuff she's buying into that as well
when you look at the Democratic party of
today it is
a party that is controlled by this
elitist cabal of War mongers
that has been continues to be
led by the queen of warmongers herself
Hillary Clinton right
it's true
the Applause delayed there people are
like wait Hillary the warmonger what
and who
who get their policies they are driven
by this uh motivation of cowardly
wokeness they are such cowards and
bloodthirsty War mongers wait but
they're they're cowards and their
weren't it doesn't make sense now why is
she doing this
I hate to to say that it's this simple
but I I believe this is this is probably
it this is how she maximizes her income
okay she's got a podcast and she gets
paid to speak and she's a Fox News
contributor Tulsi gabbard made I believe
at the time that she was a member of
Congress I think the salary was 174 000
a year
she did this run for president total
failure she got what one percent of the
vote zero I don't even she was polling
one or two percent and I don't know that
anybody voted for her totally failed not
remotely uh a progressive
um platform in reality so now she's done
the thing where she becomes right wing
the left left me the Democratic party
has failed me so that's an appealing
product and that's what it is it's a
product the former left Winger who by
the way wasn't really left so she starts
doing speaking gigs for what you know
based on her notoriety
this is a very rough guess but she could
probably get between 12 and 25
000 per speaking Gig if she has a good
speaking agent
um the podcast you know it doesn't seem
like a huge podcast but it might net her
like low six figures and then she's a
Fox News contributor probably also like
a low six-figure deal so that's the
grift she probably these are super rough
estimates she's probably making half a
million bucks a year it might be 250 it
might be 600 or 650 yeah it's something
this is the most lucrative way to
productize herself to turn herself into
the commodity of the former Democrat
who's willing to go and talk about how
vaccines are bad and trans is bad and
abortion is bad and on and on and on if
she remains a Democrat no one listens to
her podcast it's not a good podcast if
she's a Democrat she doesn't get any of
these speaking gigs because the right is
much more interested in funding oh the 4
former Democrat and if she's a Democrat
she almost certainly doesn't get uh the
Fox News contributorship and by when I
say if she's a Democrat I mean if she
continues to be at least claiming to be
on the left she could have you know
nominally remained a Democrat and done
basically the same stuff so it's it's
the grift and this is what tool C is
doing and to the extent that she's like
what's best for myself personally I get
it it's just pretty disgustingly overtly
agrift and this is where we end up uh
tools he's saying Democrats want to do
abortion after birth also at the vision
24 National conservative Forum was Nikki
Haley 2024 Republican Presidential
wannabe she didn't make any sense
she actually seems completely unable or
unwilling to explain why she's running
and uh to really uh I mean I don't if
she is auditioning to be Trump's VP that
I understand
if she is auditioning to become the next
Tulsi right who gets a gig on Fox News
and you know a podcast or something then
maybe it makes sense but she seems
visibly confused by every question here
she is saying our kids must say the
Pledge of Allegiance
[Applause]
our kids need to be be saying the Pledge
of Allegiance when they start their day
so that they know to love America
[Music]
aha
Nikki Haley who is an advocate of
freedom and liberty
is demanding that children be forced to
recite a pledge of allegiance to the
flag
and that will make them love America
freedom to be forced by schools to say
the Pledge of Allegiance huh it's kind
of kind of interesting doesn't really
make a lot of sense does it uh Nikki
Haley claims that 90 of American
children are now under critical race
Theory they're under it I think she
means under the regime of it or
something listen to this what would you
have to say about the wokism that's
infiltrating the school systems
90 of our American Kids
are now under critical race Theory they
used to be over it then they were
alongside it and now they are crushed
beneath its weight that means is if a
little girl goes into kindergarten if
she's white you're telling her she's bad
if she's brown or black you're telling
her she's never going to be good enough
and she's always going to be a victim
I missed that kindergarten class I would
like to speak to the kindergarten
teacher that is teaching that
and that's wrong the idea that we are
doing it's also not happening finding
our children based on race based on
religion based on all of these things
that's not what was supposed to happen
you have we talked about the yeah
yeah I would love for someone to ask
Nikki Haley to Define critical race
Theory and also maybe to Define wokeness
what she says is happening in
kindergarten is not happening period
it's just not happening and she is doing
the sort of youngin thing where she's
against woke and she's against CRT and
she wants the pledge taught oh right but
what like what would be the top tax rate
under your presidency I don't know
that's policy I don't deal with that one
more clip from Nikki Haley's appearance
this one is about parents rights and
schools it's the same nonsense that
they're now obsessing over problem is
these School bureaucrats have decided
parents can't do their job so they now
suddenly think they have to go and
infiltrate everything that they think
should be taught to our kids we are
still the parents we have to fight for
our kids we have one job and that's to
make sure that we raise our children to
be strong faithful responsible kids and
if we don't stop all this woke ideology
that's happening in our school goals
there it is we will lose them and we
can't afford for that to happen the
biggest critics of SP of public schools
today
have absolutely no idea what is being
taught in public schools they love to
say parents should have the right to
know what their children are being
taught and yet they have no idea what's
going on in public schools by the way
many of them send their kids to private
schools or Charter Schools anyway that's
a different story for a different day
this is what the right is today Tulsi
talking about abortion after birth Nikki
Haley talking about woke and CRT it
draws a crowd it gets Applause and by
the way if you can squeeze in a little
anti-trans rhetoric even more Applause
will anything turn this around to where
the Republican party will get back to
policy that I disagree with but policy
at least uh I don't know I don't know
what if anything will turn this around
but I'll be here waiting and if they
ever want to talk about policy I'm glad
to talk about it with them
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so last
week I played for you a clip of one of
Donald Trump's new defense attorneys Joe
takapina on MSNBC being interviewed
properly by Ari melber and lunging at
papers that Ari melber was holding
that's how Joe takapina reacted to an
actual real interview with questions
that are not just softballs we now have
a different sort of interview what's
interesting is that this was a
completely friendly interview Joe
takapina appeared last night with Fox
news's propaganda is Mark Levin
very comfortable interview very friendly
there was no lunging for papers but Joe
takapina is just as unhinged take a look
at this this is if this is the guy
that's going to defend Trump if Trump is
arrested I don't know guys I'm not sure
let's start out with just a basic
question one that really only has one
answer no matter what side of the
political fence you you sit on
does anyone actually believe that if
someone else were accused of
paying hush money to avoid a publicly
embarrassing sex scandal which the
president really denies vehemently right
but which by the way never happened
right Joe
um but regardless of that if anyone else
in that situation with these set of
facts would they be prosecuted the
answer Mark by all accounts is 100 no
now what Joe takapina and this is this
is the problem when you don't have a
real interviewer a real show right like
this when you just have a softball thing
is there's two issues here number one
it's not that they're just going after
Trump for political reasons because
Michael Cohen served prison time for
participating in this very same criminal
conspiracy so if you want to be fair
Michael Cohen's crimes were committed in
service to Trump you would think that
points to maybe Trump does have some
liability here and of course secondly
the element of this that Joe takapina
doesn't include is that what is at issue
is the laundering of the hush money
through Trump's campaign
and so the idea that oh it's just
political nobody else would be arrested
for hush money related to an affair
which they don't even do well we're
talking about a different situation a
different set of facts and money
laundering through a campaign next clip
and again Mark Levin is just useless
here it's what really is troubling
because if you think about it all decent
people well the politically opposed to
Donald Trump or in favor of Donald Trump
should be concerned about this
weaponization of a prosecutor's office
to go get a political opponent because
well if you can prove that that's what
happened that would be one thing but we
know Michael Cohen went to prison over
this so it's not merely a prosecutor
saying let's see if we can get Trump on
this Cohen was prosecuted and went to
prison for his involvement in this very
same incident now that being said
I will admit I don't think the Stormy
Daniels case is the strongest case
against Trump but maybe this will open
the floodgates for other prosecutors to
say all right it's it's time it's time
here's another clip of takapina from the
dead the Stormy Daniels case there's no
crime here the only potential crime here
Mark is that Donald Trump was an
extortion victim someone says give me
money or I'm gonna tell a nasty story
about you true or not that's even that's
absolutely irrelevant to that equation
true or not I'm going to tell a story to
the Press I'm going to embarrass you
your family unless you give me money
that's extortion 101. now remember
whether or not Trump had an affair with
Stormy Daniels whether or not stormy
extorted him which by the way if it was
extortion Trump should go after her for
extortion regardless that doesn't mean
Trump had to launder the payment through
his campaign which is what's at issue
here you could say she extorted money
out of me and I gave her the money for
an affair that never happened okay then
there wouldn't be a crime except look at
how it was handled financially and again
Levin won't Force takapina to contend
with that and takapina certainly isn't
going to
um this guy if this is the sort of
defense that you have to remember with
people like Trump
typically you've got your TV lawyers who
say one thing and then your court
lawyers who have to manage the the
situation in a different way sometimes
there's a little overlap like with that
Alina Haba who got herself into all
sorts of trouble being both Trump's TV
lawyer and real lawyer My Hope for Trump
is that takapina is not actually going
to be managing this for him if indeed
Trump is arrested tomorrow with Trump's
arrest looming he is now begging for
money begging for money first and
foremost Trump also dumping in the
George Soros stuff let me mention that
George Soros the club for no growth and
other globalist special interests
including the Koch family will spend
billions and billions of dollars against
us and they don't have our interest at
heart they want a president that can be
controlled like a puppet and that's
exactly guys it's it's all the words
right Soros puppet globalist exactly
what they get with somebody like Joe
Biden instead our movement is funded by
Patriots like you who are fighting to
take our country back so the context
here is we need money to fight against
Soros and the indictment and the whole
thing and to make America great again
nothing terrifies Soros more than seeing
millions and millions of hard-working
Americans donating 5 20 even 47 there
you go when George Soros at age 92 plots
against Trump by getting him arrested
and he sees Joe Blow donating 47 dollars
Soros is just quaking in his boots look
at the imaginary fantasy world he has to
create in order to get people to donate
money to save our country from Democrats
destruction you see what they're doing
to our cities they're being destroyed
together we will make America great
again yeah yeah make America great again
Trump then posting also continuing to
ask for money on Truth social quote if
you're doing poorly as so many of you
are don't send anything if you're doing
well which was made possible through the
great policies of the Trump
Administration send your contribution to
donaldjtrump.com we have to take back
our Capital C country and all caps make
America great again that that's like a
little extra thing in there
if you're not doing well today it's
because of Joe Biden
if you are doing well today it's because
of my policies from years ago but send
Trump the money if you're doing well for
whatever reason send Trump the money
begging for cash as his arrest looms can
he even possibly raise enough money for
the number of criminal cases that there
could critical word could be
coming up against him we will see and we
will see if indeed he gets arrested
tomorrow
Alex Jones the Infowars conspiracy
theorist you know that he's going to
weigh in on the allegedly looming arrest
of the failed former president Donald
Trump here is Alex Jones with some kind
of emergency alert of some kind here's
his I challenge you to understand his
explanation of what's going on this
indictment of trump will make him the
number one candidate he's already
Emerald candidate this will add 10 15
points to him in in the Republican
primary polls okay so first of all I
actually don't think Jones is wrong with
that I do think initially if Trump is
arrested and it doesn't directly
interfere with his campaign it will help
him I don't know about 10 to 15 points I
was thinking more like six to eight but
I I agree with this part at least in
principle well absolutely shut out to
sanus you have to ask yourself if this
is assured like Elon Musk said to win
Trump the presidency in 2024 in a
landslide why on Earth will the system
be doing it
because they're scared it's the same
reason the U.N just indicted Vladimir
Putin for evacuating children from a war
zone something that happens in every
major war
including in England during World War II
including in Russia during World War II
as well
So within a matter of days in fact it
was Friday that both
Trump are you following this God I hope
someone is following this and can
explain it got the news he'd be indicted
and that Vladimir Putin was indicted so
whether you love Trump or hate Trump
whether you like Putin or hate Putin you
have to understand this is part of the
same globalist system that is moving
against leaders they believe are not in
line with their operations right
globalished exactly
um why do these sort of unique events I
mean listen the the in the arrest of a
former president if it happens it's
never happened before it's literally an
unprecedented event in the United States
why do these events trigger these wild
conspiracy theories which by the way
they always seem to somehow be very
Putin friendly but that's another part
of it
um when you have something happen that
is unprecedented or rare or difficult to
comprehend in some sense
it triggers people's assumptions about
the world and it makes them sometimes
question them
and when you have something the
indictment of a president counts but
something like a horrible school
shooting which also triggered horrible
conspiracy theories from Alex Jones when
the events are complicated or difficult
to understand or horrible or whatever
people end up uncertain and they end up
confused and in such situations people
might look for comfort in an alternative
explanation or narrative
that is coherent and makes them feel
like things are less uncertain around
them and so one of the things that
conspiracy theories often do is they
simplify Complex events oh Sandy Hook
right we've got uh the interplay between
um the gun culture and ready access to
guns and then some people say mental
health and then someone goes what about
video games and then someone says what
about woke and right although woke was
not a subject then all the stuff
people don't want to believe wow a
random horrible event caused by all of
these different factors it's easier in
met for some people
to say it was a planned and staged event
that's what this was and that's why
where you get to that now here it's all
it's kind of the opposite sometimes
conspiracy theories take something
simple that people just don't want to
believe and they dress it up to make it
more complicated well there might just
be evidence Trump committed a crime and
so he would be arrested nope don't like
that conclusion so instead it's the
international criminal court is
coordinating the Trump arrest with
charging Putin because of some
evacuations and globalists and then also
DeSantis and the polling and all this
different stuff so sometimes a
conspiracy theorist's motive is to
simplify a truly complex event sometimes
a conspiracy theorist motive is to make
a simple event whose explanation you
don't like much more complicated so
people go wow I don't know what the hell
is it behind this well maybe what's
behind it is there's evidence Trump
committed a crime and what would be
appropriate in a country with
accountability would be an arrest am I
convinced the arrest is coming tomorrow
I'm not but in the context where we
believe it is that would be the
explanation behind what Alex Jones is
doing here we have a voicemail number
you can call anytime here is a call at
2192 David P about the Spanish Channel
Dave it's Alan from Jersey I can't stand
every single day you keep promoting the
Spanish channel on the English Channel
well I didn't promote it today
I'm not interested in Spanish I don't
speak more than a couple words in
Spanish I don't want Spanish stop
promoting the Spanish Channel but more
importantly than that anybody that's
listening to the English Channel can
speak English so they don't need to go
to the Spanish Channel because they
already know English
it's like 18 it's like drive through
ATMs that have Braille you know we say
oh that's great you know people who are
blind can use braille at the ATM but
what blind person is going to drive up
to the ATM okay beautiful analogy except
it doesn't really work so let me just
explain something here I understand you
like I I'm not blind to the reality
that if you're listening to this show in
English you probably speak English great
okay fantastic that being said lots of
people know others
who don't have the English language
capacity to take this type of content in
English but they do in Spanish and so I
have this huge platform that I've spent
time building and many of you know
people who would like a Spanish version
of the show that's why I say hey we make
a lot of this show now available in
Spanish for people who prefer that and
so for example if you are a 22 year old
whose parents immigrated to the U.S and
they speak conversational English but
would rather political content in
Spanish you can tell them hey the David
Pacman show that I listen to is
available in Spanish for you guys
um so I I don't know if you know that
that's more or less the explanation all
right we've got a great bonus show for
you today producer Pat is back we will
find out what he was up to
we will talk about the impact of the
fact that police departments were not
defunded but some have chosen to
downsize why what's going on we will
discuss Kevin McCarthy is telling
Americans don't protest if Trump is
arrested does Kevin McCarthy have the
right idea and lastly California has
entered a contract to make its own
insulin and to make it affordable we
will talk about how this will work
whether it will work and so much more on
today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad join me my friends let's make
money on the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com and don't worry we will
be back tomorrow with a new show you
better believe it
foreign